there are a handful of countries today  that can be accurately described as  social democracies modern social  democracies allow egalitarianism things  like social welfare universal health  care and representative democracy to  flourish within the context of  capitalism think of countries like  denmark finland norway iceland sweden so  modern social democracy is sometimes  referred to as the nordic model these  countries have free college free  graduate school free or inexpensive  world-class health care  paid through taxes compared to other  developed countries generally speaking  they have lower rates of crime and a  higher quality of life